we've been hearing a lot about the
strikes but here are the ones you might
not have heard of they've been called
off after last minute pay offers were
accepted let's have a quick look at
those Rolls-Royce Motors threatened to
strike and were given a pay Award of
17.6 the tssa one of the Rel unions have
agreed to a deal somewhere between 9 and
11 which the rmt union is still
rejecting and baggage handlers working
at Heathrow suspended their walkout to
consider a pay rise of 10 and a half
percent now these are all Above All
Around current inflation of 10.7 now
contrast that to the deadlock continuing
in other sectors look at these pay
offers for example nurses ambulances and
Royal Mail for nurses in fact the
difference is stuck the independent pay
review body recommended four to five
percent but nurses are demanding 19
border Force covered by the Civil
Service Union the PCS has been offered
two percent but they want 10. now the
governments say they're being Guided by
independent pay bodies leading to
questions over whether their
recommendations are out of date and they
need to reopen and review them that
suggestion rejected by a former pay
Review Board member
the thing that's really changed is the
level of pay Awards going on elsewhere
and there's no doubt that wages in the
economy generally both private sector
and increasingly in the public sector
are higher than the review body would
have thought they were last January
February when they were taking evidence
and therefore my thought on how this
Dreadful dispute could be progressed is
to ask the review body not to reopen its
last year's recommendations which I
think would be a mistake for both
parties but to say
let's do the next round very quickly
now what is decided both sides are so
ingrained that this stalemate will
undoubtedly run Beyond Christmas and
into the new year